" Emission spéciale inédite ce soir
jusqu’à 22h, nous allons plonger ensemble
au cœur du débat national
qui a démarré il y a à peu près
un mois dans tout le pays. "
Tout de suite, je pense qu’il y a
quelque chose à faire autour du grand débat.
On est une chaîne de prises de parole
parce que c’est le propre de
l’histoire de l’Assemblée en réalité.
Donc, même si ça a lieu à côté
c’est un instrument de revitalisation
démocratique et on doit, nous, l’accompagner.
On ne va pas sur les débats
où il y a le Président Macron.
Moi ce qui m’intéresse, c’est le fait
que précisément on donne la parole aux Français.
Et pas au Président de la République,
puisqu’il l’avait déjà.
" - Allez-y, Monsieur.
- Oui, bien, bonjour à tous,
je voudrais vous parler d’un problème
un problème de pauvreté.
Voilà… Excusez-moi, je…
- Allez-y, n’ayez crainte!
Vous êtes ému? C’est pas grave.
- Je reviens sur la TVA.
Je pensais comme Madame, baisser
la TVA sur les produits de première nécessité
et pourquoi pas augmenter
sur les produits de luxe?
- Je pense que dès lors que
vous avez des revenus en France
vous devez être taxé en France
point à la ligne! "
Les Français se sont appropriés ce moment,
donc il faut qu’on l’accompagne.
Et là, j’ai dit on va faire
une grammaire sportive
c’est-à-dire qu’on va faire un multiplex
comme il y avait des multiplex
pour les journées de championnat
les journées importantes
de championnat de foot.
" - Nous serons en direct
de 4 villes sur tout le territoire
et vous êtes tous, tous les 4
sur place en multiplex!
- Bonsoir Myriam, Saint-Germain-Laprade,
commune de 3600 habitants!
- Nous sommes donc à Croix,
dans le département du Nord.
- Je me trouve à la Maison de la Vie Associative
et Citoyenne dans le 18ème arrondissement de Paris.
- Bienvenue ici à Grand-Champ,
le débat vous le voyez
vient de commencer sur le thème
de la fiscalité et du pouvoir d’achat.
Ici, il y a les organisateurs,
regardez, vous l’avez dit
ils sont issus du mouvement des Gilets jaunes,
mais ils n’ont pas mis le gilet jaune
ils ont tenu à le dire:
ce soir, ce sont d’abord des citoyens. "
On avait des gens en plateau qui
pouvaient avoir une analyse un peu savante
mais en même temps on avait
la traduction, si j’ose dire in situ
par ce qu’il se passait dans tel
ou tel endroit qu’on avait choisi.
" Force est de constater
qu’on n’y arrive pas
on n’y arrive pas peut-être parce
qu'on ne va pas vers les citoyens
pour essayer de poser une fiscalité
qui soit un peu plus juste
et donc mieux comprise
et mieux acceptée.
C’est une condition même,
me semble-t-il de la démocratie. "
Là on est au cœur non seulement
de notre mission mais d’un projet intéressant
c’est-à-dire qu’on a
à la fois une parole incarnée
qui est la parole des Français
et on a une parole,
j’allais dire distanciée
qui est la parole des gens qui réfléchissent
le pays, qui l’analysent, qui l’étudient etc.
Et je trouvais que c’était bien
de les faire se rencontrer.